let's jump into this first story and
talk about the the world is changing so
quickly yep elon musk acquires 9.2 stake
in twitter the world's richest man is
now the social media giant's largest
shareholder my understanding is that
he's also the largest uh uh he has the
largest vote he's bigger than uh
vanguard i think whatever whatever
yeah i thought it was like is it
blackrock yeah i thought maybe yeah
they uh timbers.com writes on monday a
filing with the securities and exchange
commission revealed that elon musk has
acquired a 9.2 stake in the social media
giant the move by musk reportedly the
world's richest man comes just weeks
after he started criticizing the
platform for its violations of free
speech his criticism was followed by a
rumor that he might create a new
competing platform similar to twitter
the icc filing shows that he purchased
roughly 73.4 million shares in the
company making him the largest
shareholder on twitter according
according to the financial times jack
founder only holds 2.25 stake in twitter
musk has not spoken publicly about the
acquisition previously indicated he
wanted to see dramatic changes on
twitter of course he has a bunch of
tweets he says i'm giving serious
thought to this um he was tweeting about
free speech saying what should be done
i don't know if he can do anything he
conducted a poll on twitter asking his
followers if they think twitter regular
rigorously adheres to the principles of
free speech he noted the consequence of
the online poll would be significant
seventy percent of the two million
twitter respondents said no
that's crazy the first few months of new
twitter ceo parag agrawal's tenure have
validated some concerns his leadership
would reduce free expression since
agarwal took the position at twitter the
site permabanned one of the accounts of
congressman marjorie taylor greene for
allegedly violating its covet-19
misinformation policy and then of course
she uh heavily criticized them recently
former new york times reporter alex
berenson sued twitter over his band
august 2020
and uh then we also have an editor's
note full correction initial reporting
said 9.7 there were a few outlets at 9.7
it was 9.2 the big question ladies and
gentlemen does this matter
i feel very tired and bored by these
conversations about twitter and you know
i mean you got fired over twitter so
maybe it matters no maybe it doesn't
matter well i mean twitter didn't fire
me so i mean technically it doesn't
matter but i don't know i just
i we keep hearing these stories coming
out about how like so and so starting a
new social media company and this is
finally going to change things and i
just feel always disappointed like i'm
super black-pilled about just the
general idea of social media um not just
because of censorship reasons but
because of the effect that it's having
on our you know societal interactions
and the way kids are raised and all of
these different things social media
addiction
i don't even i don't know how much power
this actually gives elon musk um
i've seen people smarter than i say that
quite a lot apparently i i hope that it
changes i guess i'm just generally
pessimistic about the state of social
media in general and i don't even know
if twitter's really worth saving at this
point because you you have to change not
just the policies in terms of you know
the vaccine misinformation you weren't
allowed to say for a while there that if
you had the vaccine that you could still
get coveted you could still spread covet
and really stupid things like that but
there's also a lot of algorithmic issues
in terms of how they decide what content
gets promoted what content gets shadow
banned and things like that so there's
there's so many things that need to
change across the board to make this a
better platform
and i mean hopefully elon musk is the
guy to help do it but again i
i don't have high hopes for anything
regarding twitter facebook instagram
whatever some people are saying that he
does get substantial voting power and he
could move to make himself a board
member and then as a board member he can
make some real changes he's charismatic
too yeah you need to be on the board
well maybe be on the board so he
vanguard owns 8.39 at least this is from
cnn so he is the largest stakeholder now
the thing is so you want to talk about
changing the terms of service to make it
a free speech network you could base it
out of like connecticut and then you
have to adhere to to state law uh
corporate law but then the thing is the
nsa can come in and say hey we don't
like that guy shut us a countdown and
you're not allowed to tell anyone here's
a gag order and then they have to
because they have the data if you don't
know who the people are and you don't
have their data you can't the cia can't
come and take it from you you see in nsa
interchangeably it's crazy um i think
really honestly
forcing companies to change their terms
of service
is a big ask and it feels very fascist
to use political force to make a private
company do something like that i think
that free speech on the internet is a
different kind of free speech and that
it's more about the code because if it's
spying on you and you don't know you're
not really free if you're if you're
constantly being watched and sold out
behind or or possibly
a better a question is if the algorithms
are hidden and people are being shadow
banned and silenced without you knowing
then you're not in a fair system you
should know the nsa came and they shut
that they took that data they shut that
guy down that you should always know
that stuff because you see it happen on
the network yeah and a lot of times
twitter doesn't even tell people why
they're being banned i mean they say
sometimes you're being removed for this
tweet and you have to delete it
otherwise you're not allowed you have a
suspension but sometimes they don't
really tell people and then when
inevitably
usually conservative in an independent
media go up in arms about what's going
on they say oh it was just a mistake you
know somebody in inaccurately flagged
this tweet for violating terms of
service and so they're really not
transparent about even when people are
violating things what specific policy
they're violating or which tweet was the
violation sometimes they'll say that
somebody was getting around a previous
band by creating new accounts or that
their email address has multiple
accounts registered to it and it all
just seems like they're playing these
games to try to get around
actually enforcing their policies fairly
across the board i think that if someone
gets banned if account gets banned that
the the the ban reason should be on the
blockchain for them for reference i
think yeah but then what if they put
bunk
info on the blockchain and well you
should be able to appeal it and then the
appeal should be on the blockchain you
should be able to watch the process if
it was that's true because then you can
see they lied because check out this
story this is from a year ago twitter
bans james o'keefe yeah of project
veritas over fake account policy in
suggesting that he was operating
multiple accounts in an unsanctioned way
o'keefe has already announced that he
will sue the company for defamation and
that's legit because james was like i
didn't operate multiple accounts and
when you asked twitter about this
because i've done this i reached out to
them about this exact
issue and i have a press contact at
twitter that like claims to be from
conservative world so they're always
like oh well we'll put you the
conservative media journalist to reach
out to this person because they can be
trusted because they used to work for a
republican or whatever it's all bs but i
reach out to them about these types of
issues all the time of them claiming
that people got banned for these account
violations and when you ask for evidence
of it what they tell you is oh well it's
a personnel issue or it's a company
policy issue and we can't talk anymore
about it and even with james himself and
other people who have had this happen to
them they won't talk about it with them
either so how are you supposed to get
any accountability when they keep doing
this to people i i wonder where james
james is with this lawsuit because i
mean
they banned him and then outright made a
statement about something he did
that he didn't do yeah with no evidence
and so he can easily just say to a judge
like your honor i didn't operate
multiple accounts they claimed i did
that's defamation the judge is good i
have to imagine he's gonna be like okay
let's let's go to discovery and easily
determine whether or not he was or
wasn't
yeah i think that's exactly right the
other problem with twitter in particular
is that they have this sort of corporate
structure where they're hiring these
kids who are on college campuses like
protesting against speakers and shutting
people down those are the people that
are getting hired at the big tech
companies and those are the ones that
are actually in charge of enforcing the
terms of service so you already have you
have the biased algorithms and then you
have an extra layer of bias with the
people who are in charge of actually
enforcing the policies and so it's
really no wonder that things like this
happen so if elon's going to get in here
he has to
basically go through the entire payroll
of twitter and try to root out some of
these people who are acting as activists
as opposed to people who are trying to
fairly enforce terms of service so the
reason why blockchain administration
would be good because if you have a
bunch of miscalculations of bans that
weren't right you'd be like oh it was on
december 23rd who was admitting on
december 23rd at 4 pm is all accountable
i you may want these corporations may
want to hide that from the public
because they want to protect their
employees and i get that to a point but
also the public when it's in the commons
the public deserves i believe the
control of the system and knowing who's
screwing with the system this is the
commons i think elon also sees this as
the commons i'm i was uh listening to
something about tick tock and some some
young tic tacker was like oh yeah
twitter's dumb
it's just for like politics no one cares
and i think that's a fair assessment too
many of us are on twitter because it's a
political social network that's what it
is it's politics and journalism
everything else is like what's the point
you're gonna go there and follow
you know brad pitt for whatever reason
or whatever celebrate not really you're
not and that's why even the new york
times gets no interaction on any of
their tweets the real point of twitter
is to go on and be mean to people and
emotionally destroy them well the second
reason is to talk about news politics
and social media you can also message
people directly which is pretty cool
like i sent jordan a message yesterday
i've never met him before but peterson
yeah peterson oh yeah jordan peterson
disagree with your third of your
40-second rules dude your third one
talks about always being honest
sometimes laws are bad and you can't be
honest about it
anyway we'll talk about that later but
yeah i wonder if twitter just becomes a
relevant in 10 years
it very well could i mean i've there's
always this phrase that people throw out
right twitter's not real life and it's
100 true i mean i'm like a twitter
obsessed full and i go out and i talk to
my friends or my family back home about
this stupid tweet i saw and they have no
idea what i'm talking about or some
manufactured controversy that left-wing
activists on twitter are all up in arms
about and again nobody who even people
who like consume fox news or cnn
incessantly don't really know what's
going on on twitter unless they are
actively on there for multiple hours a
day but this but twitter does have a
huge impact on policy it does so
it's it's almost like the forefront of
thought in a lot of ways when it comes
to politics and journalism you'll get
someone like uh david hogg had a tweet
which is which is really important it is
because seeing his internal monologue
his inner monologue is important to
understand that you shouldn't listen to
his advice on anything right when he
tweeted
you need what do you say you need a
license to kill deer why don't you need
a license to kill humans yeah as if to
imply you're allowed to or like you
could go to the government be like i
would like to kill people like well
here's your license to kill sir like
yeah you can't kill people
like they're they're only you know
extenuating circumstances you're
defending yourself or you're in war or
something but
normally these activists and
high-profile profile individuals
would go through some several filters
before that message would actually get
out now because of twitter people are
just thinking things and then tweeting
it right you know i take advantage of
that and just tweet things that i know
are intentionally ridiculous and then
it's weird you know you know i think
works for the left is that
most of most of the leftists know my
tweets tend to be nonsense but they know
their followers don't so they're like i
can retweet this guy and even though i
know it's sarcasm or something or
silliness or trolling but everyone else
take it seriously but anyway i digress
the point is
aoc talks about the green new deal you
know these these politicians talk about
policy positions and plans and they
manifest on twitter antifa organizes
rallies on twitter so sure you can be
one of these older guys on fox news
having no idea what's going on and then
one day you look out your window and
this guy throwing a molotov cocktail you
know at your building and you're like
why is that happening well
look at twitter they were talking about
it for the past three days there was a
shift in i don't know it was 2013 2012.
all of a sudden cnn started getting
screenshots of tweets like like i was
from the pre-internet age before
social media and then i would make a
bunch of youtube videos then all of a
sudden it was like it's a big deal to
get mentioned on tv then all of a sudden
the news is no longer on cnn the news is
on twitter cnn's referencing twitter
tweets tweets they're referencing tweets
on cnn
yeah and it's not the problem is twitter
only has as much value and power as we
assign to it and media companies in
particular have assigned a lot of value
to what people say on twitter whether
negative or positive they will pull up
random accounts with like 30 followers
and be screenshotting their tweets and
putting them on a primetime cable news
program as if this is like a serious
person with real thoughts that matter in
the public square
and i mean it's gotten to this point now
where
i think you're right that twitter is
setting a lot of policy i mean i would
love to know for example where like the
don't say gay moniker came from i
wouldn't be surprised if that came from
some left-wing twitter account some like
12-year-old yeah that's the funniest
thing about cnn putting tweets on tv is
that it's probably some 12-year-old kid
who you know tweeted
having no idea this is actually a really
important point on twitter you you don't
know you're arguing arguing with a 14
year old the dude who got
uh harry's razors to to dump daley wire
claims to have been in high school
i wouldn't doubt it and so just think
about how insane that is that some high
school kid desperate for attention or to
like have an impact because it's you
know it's trolling right you want you
want to feel your pressure or your
presence on the world sees a story takes
their account and it'll be called like
you know bro dude 54 and they tweet i
think joe biden is the greatest
president donald trump was bad because
you know he was racist and then cnn's
like here's a tweet from someone who
matters and it's like it's just some 12
year old kid who has no idea what he's
talking about i knew a dude who who gave
a fake interview to a local there was a
plane crash in chicago and this dude ran
there afterwards and then told the
journalists that he had seen it he's
like oh yeah he's like i was here when
it happened and they said what happened
and he just made a story up because he
wanted to be on tv
now he was an adult at the time but
imagine a 12 year old they'd be like i
don't know you know where your parents
so you can be 12 go on twitter
say joe biden's economic plan is
destabilizing this country and then a
network will be like we should put that
tweet up and show people
when you're getting your opinions from a
rant from a random assortment it could
be children have no idea what they're
talking about and that's probably true a
lot for the left because the left tends
the democrats tend to have a lot more
younger people
so imagine just all of these
conservatives on twitter arguing with
people and it's like a 56 year old guy
arguing with a 14 year old just just
don't do it don't argue not in text it's
it's never good thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you